hello welcome back everybody we're gonna
take a quick roll call before we get
started yeah who's here
Gina's here TIFF is here jess is here
and Nikki's here we were missing a
couple girls right now because Bo's
works late and yeah does this shoot
earlier yep and then uh Gigi was
supposed to be here but she had some mom
stuff that she was taking care of
yep but that's kind of fitting because
today I wanted to talk about family the
holidays coming up oh you said today was
like oh my god what are we talking about
did I agree to this by the way stranger
to find us baby mama I'm gonna jump into
my car a stranger I couldn't wait
stranger you know adorable like chubby
like you got a judge a book by its cover
yeah I was I was not picturing a chubby
hipster cuz what you said hipster I just
picked her like a skinny guy that looked
like he could either be a history like
Seth Rogen if he was the dad even
drinking way too much ghee and it's also
I don't know if you could tell but we're
on a different set it looks really
similar but we're coming up with a new
set for 2020 yeah what a temporary set
right now but yeah let's get into this
so holidays guys in America for those of
you of people that aren't from America
they're listening we do Thanksgiving and
Christmas and they're super tied
together and you see your family
typically at one or both of those things
so it can either be a really happy time
for people that are like oh my god I
miss my family so much and we do all
these cool things or some people get a
little sad because they're like I don't
really see my family that much or I
don't really have any family or we don't
do really cool things it's like kind of
depressing or whatever and I think that
was I think it's really important to
acknowledge the yeah because that nobody
loves
[Laughter]
that's what I do for holidays I roast
everyone in my family like because I
haven't been invited in open fire yeah
because I feel like people out there
think that they're alone in the whole
holiday family I think that's what a big
part of that seasonal depression thing
is a season of extra people just because
it's Holi
yeah suicide there are sponsors everyone
lis celebrates their holidays because
everyone does it different and I always
want to say here's the thing all right
I'm gonna put it out there right now I
hate white people food on Thanksgiving
oh my god truly do do you know just wait
so you just like I want to talk about
this later some for Thanksgiving it
doesn't work like breakfast
see the thing is turkey is [ __ ] oh of
course
everyone knows yeah no no I well don't
like Turkey
okay good a lot of duck or what yeah I
like duck we had prime rib last year and
what if somebody brings a turkey to my
house you're getting thrown out Wow we
don't like it I will let you know though
like not all white people eat the same
Thanksgiving because my dad is from the
south and he's a Texan and like so he'll
[ __ ] barbecue wreaths I'll do all
kinds of [ __ ] on Thanksgiving besides
just but I have to request a traditional
Thanksgiving dinner in order to get it
so not everyone is the same okay
people like an audition okay Gina we
usually go to my Filipino side for
Thanksgiving and missing though because
like everyone married a different race
so it's like the core Filipino family
and we have one set and we have like
rice and lumpia and all of the
traditional adobo yes
oh yeah what not even one but you've
never had beautiful I'm gonna bring some
leftovers she's sitting right here
that's all she's like the way that's
true I learned how to cook all the
Filipino dishes from my mom my white mom
who learned from my Filipino grandma
like a white space in-between the
Filipino so I feel like there's a notch
of whether your grandma like you're
actually no grandma's house yeah dude
she makes the best food the best lumpia
by far oh yeah we're going to your mouth
for sure comes later because there's
like so many in-laws there's like white
people food so they've got the turkey
all the traditional foods a cranberry
sauce and then a favorite by the way
cranberry sauce and it has to come from
the can that's my family right yeah Joe
gelatinous like the shape of the cab and
then you just slice it in between the
ridges yeah so y'all just get like a
slice of cranberry yeah bomb like I like
to mix it I'm a mixer what do you mix it
on like corn bread in my it tastes
really good oh wow it especially make a
sandwich with all that [ __ ] the next day
oh yeah no my Thanksgivings every year
it was always so my birthday's on the
29th of November so sometimes it's like
right after actually this year it lands
on Black Friday I believe so my so
Thanksgivings always like shared with my
birthday and because of that every year
around the holidays cause like for me
holidays begin like Halloween or
sometimes they'll be Thanksgiving and
then I'm like oh my god it's the
holidays already where did the year go
by like oh my god it this is every year
it sneaks up on me yeah every year and
I'm like to have it and then there's
Christmas and then right after Christmas
Isaac's birthday and I'm like oh my god
so this time of the year it goes by so
fast
funny own your kid it takes forever to
get to the holidays but when you're an
adult you're like what the wasn't it
just January what the hell
yeah 20 soon no Gina
stop my older next year like every other
year but really old my student dude I
legit forgot that aging was part of a
birthday this year people were like what
you do for your birthday I was like I
did this to this and they're like how
old were you I was like oh [ __ ] I forgot
your age
so is there I know that TIFF has
different plans this year for
Thanksgiving
what are you guys's plans well I guess
I'll start then yeah oh my god guys I'm
so freaking excited for this year so I
have finally booked my solo trip that I
have been dying to do like practically
my whole life I've always wanted to do a
solo trip and not just any like any
destination where are you going girl I'm
going to Bora Bora oh I'm so freaking so
for the last 10 years Bora Bora has been
like my heaven on earth like my dream
destination like if you asked me if you
had a plane ticket anywhere in the world
right now where would you go it my
answer for the last 10 years has been
Bora Bora now it's happening so
untreated dreams are coming true so
you're doing the opposite of golden ear
then yeah exactly the end of your golden
year it totally it's like such so I'm
turning 30 this year and so I'm gonna
end up spending Thanksgiving and my
birthday alone and it sounds sad but I
am so excited and like this is literally
the one thing that I have just been
dreaming for and like I feel like my
soul needs it like I've never
experienced being alone like for my
entire life you know I had Isaac when I
was 18 and I've been in a relationship
ever since I was 16 like I've just never
really had alone time I love it how long
are you going for um so it's about a
week yeah I imagine like she's sitting
on the beach with a drink and then like
Isaac in case you're having a meltdown
message
no I actually told Casey I'm like listen
I'll text you every night to tell you
like to make sure that I'm safe so I'm
just I'm literally just gonna text I'm
safe and then turn my phone off like
don't bother me I don't like no one like
world does not exist but it's so cute
because they're gonna go camping during
the time that I'm gone so they're gonna
spend like Father father-son time it's
okie us then two alone yeah Gimli just
the two of them that's so cute I lots of
you in this dream the moment you pull up
to the airport and Babur I'm like sup
talk about work I want to be included in
everything she's like I'm just having a
good time this holiday no but I did feel
really guilty though booking this trip
because I know get over it I'll be
camping he'll be doing boy stuff like
I'm kid because he is like that entire
week that I'm gone he's out of school
and like I rarely get to see him so I
feel really guilty but Casey ended up
convincing me like I you know I think
you really need this trip and don't
worry Isaac's gonna be fine we're gonna
spend time together but he saw it in my
eyes like you need this and also because
I was looking a good man yeah he's such
a good guy so he I was also trying to
look for a cheaper destination cuz Borg
war is freaking expensive and it takes
forever to get there because it's in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean and so I was
trying to look at like Hawaii or
somewhere in the Caribbean and like I'm
not special
it's yeah Casey was like honestly he's
like baby no matter where you go if it's
not Bora Bora it's not gonna make you
happy so you should go to Bora Bora and
I'm like oh my god send some home photos
I'll try yeah I need a tripod oh we're
also doing something completely
different this Thanksgiving we're going
to Vegas which yeah you but my whole
family's going to Vegas it's similar
thing where my brother's wife so my
sister-in-law it's her birthday and it's
her 21st birthday woah yeah and she's
bluie sober she just had my godson yeah
and she just wanted to do something fun
and and so yeah the whole family he just
agreed to like go out to ok thanks
giving yeah so it's weird because it's
still family but it's just a break in
tradition and then my grandma my
Filipino grandma heard that we weren't
going no she's like she's like she's
like oh yeah yeah I'm going to Missouri
so my dad's birthday falls on the 27th
so I always come so I'm actually gonna
be missing Thanksgiving a little bit I'm
going for my dad's birthday so we're all
like missing Thanksgiving yeah yeah so
I'm flying in and I can only do I can
only stay for like two days cuz I have
work but I'm flying in celebrating
Thanksgiving earlier with my dad and his
birthday and I'm gonna fly out but what
we usually do for the holidays ISM so I
used to always spend the holidays or
Thanksgiving with my mom's side of the
family and it's like my Chinese side and
they're like what we do is we eat a ton
and then the uncles all get drunk and
then they gamble and that's the best
it's the best right
but then lately I've been spending more
time with my dad so I would just fly to
Missouri and what's the fun part is half
my family what there's white like super
white like really why I didn't like the
way Thanksgiving I don't but I love the
family because like okay so um my whole
side of the family like they're there
they're like large
people like a mayor
can white tall [ __ ] and like they're
like heavier set but they're like the
biggest teddy bear you have no no this
is my steps okay yeah okay that's what
that so um and they're like the sweetest
people in the world and then like this
goes into like Christmas also but
grandpa so let's say their last thing
I'm not gonna give him your last the
real last name let's say their last name
is Smith Smith right so like you don't
call them my name or grandpa or whatever
you call them grandpa's smooth the
normal thing is to call them like pawpaw
yeah like some weird name I heard my my
weight I actually both both sides I
called them Papa Papa and Grandma mm-hmm
yeah I don't poop it wasn't there like
last day but yeah like Papa Papa Danny
yeah I would never use our like grandpa
Smith always wraps up with a single
candy bar for each kid Oh cute we all
like a dirty old woman like I love this
kid dude so my oh my Filipino side for
Christmas they have the same Santa who's
like their neighbor like that from back
when I was like before was born it's the
same Santa every year comes comes in and
my aunt buys all the presents and that
he brings the presents now all the kids
are like 30 it's not creepy but uh but
yeah it's it's just yeah it's funny
does this man have kid no no anyway he
has a wife so it's mrs. Claus mrs. Claus
is always there - yeah and then he
always like um Mike the neighbor always
comes over right after Santa leaves
[Laughter]
start I don't know I think my aunt just
likes to do cute little traditions like
that and so
and she's the one that always throws the
parties and she like she's very like
this yeah like loves like to host a
party and like have all the cool things
there and so yeah she does that and then
we usually do like a name drawing so
there's like Secret Santas and there's
all kinds of all kinds of little [ __ ]
like that but we don't really we don't
really do that anymore because uh my
aunt and uncle got divorced and so so
she still has like Santa come over to
like her house but that's how she's
drunk by now you're [ __ ] 30 years
[Laughter]
older with an accent oh yeah let's throw
it to me yeah I have the sad story
oh sweet let's throw it to the natives
for since its wedding yeah yeah so what
are you gonna use for so we're gonna use
our favorite new brand native deodorant
do you wanna give that a little smell so
native is formulated without aluminum
parabens and talc it is filled with
ingredients found in nature such as
coconut oil shea butter and tapioca
starch and it's never tested on animals
Oh important ish yes it smells really
good I love it
Joe has it and I smelled him wearing it
the other day jakey news and I was like
anyway so native offers free shipping
and returns also making the switch to
aluminum free deodorant does not mean
having to sacrifice on performance test
it out and let us know
they have over 9,000 five-star refuse
and less is more with native okay I'm
coming as ever have you guys ever um
accidentally licked deodorant
what accidentally yeah oh you mean the
guy yeah oh I was like I thought you
took a stick a were like you're licked a
guy's armpit yeah cuz like I just like
we're just laying in bed and she's like
me being cheeky like bull I know that he
accidentally moved you know cuz I was
going oh yes Lee moved and got a
mouthful of butyrate crisper it makes
your mouth dry oh yeah well if you guys
want to try native for 20% off your
first purchase visit native deodorant
calm and use promo code b-tch 20 during
checkout again for 20% off your first
purchase visit native deodorant calm and
use promo code b-tch 20 during checkout
and we also want to give a shout out to
hello fresh fresh I know you like hello
fresh what do you like about it
dude send me more food hello fresh bite
the payment I don't care
oh wait am I love to say that hey I got
my shipment and it was really good I
mean that I made the tacos last week
yeah man I actually look like I knew
what I was doing I do know what a zoo
but I'd look like a really and they send
you an apron and like I was about to ask
you did you wear the apron just watching
myself it's very foolproof way they do
it like thank you
fresh ingredients and then they have
like exactly how much you want you need
for the recipe and then exactly what to
do with it mmm they said look like a
picture everything yeah and then they
send you like this little piece of paper
that shows you how to do it and what
it's supposed to look like in case you
at the end and it's also super flexible
you can add extra meal
so your weekly order change delivery
days they have vegan and they have
families they have all kinds of
different diets and everything family
sizes mmm
so there's a bunch of five-star recipes
has more five-star recipes than any
other meal kit I tried other ones and
they're kind of yeah and so for a
limited time only you get nine free
meals with hellofresh
go to hell afresh calm slash b tch nine
and enter b TCH nine again for a limited
time only get nine free meals with my
gosh and hellofresh calm slash b TCH
nine and enter b TCH nine yeah alright
and your life so this year i am single
and ya know I'm actually happy about
being single but now that the holidays
are coming around I'm like kind of
getting sad again no no not too sad but
just enough to like notice it so usually
for the last like four years I've gone
to my ex's family's house for
Thanksgiving and Christmas and I have a
whole family and they have the kids and
everything there's just a lot different
though it's not traditional at all
because number one they're Japanese like
pretty Japanese and then number two they
they are like pescetarian so samurai
sword fights yeah super it's like super
Asian so I haven't really had the
traditional thing in a while anyway so
like that's totally fine but I'm not
gonna have probably any Thanksgiving
this year unless that someone is having
a friendsgiving welcome to Vegas Vegas
Vegas love you for real I'm gonna do cuz
I'm just like um is anyone having a
friendly just that for Christmas girl
gonna be gone your comments I told you
you're coming with us we're uh so the
Chan clans come in from Texas and wolves
they're coming here yeah yeah you gonna
fly anywhere you're not going anywhere
I'm say you're gonna be at our house
table they're not gonna be alone for
Christmas yeah that's cool yeah but so
um yeah I was thinking about just doing
like a lot of self-care stuff during the
holidays and you know a lot of spa days
and bro I'll be bad a lot of writing and
a lot of something no not running
I'm not gonna be here yeah I want to fly
back 128th we can go to we spawn just
dick around in the end okay so some
people might be wondering why I'm not
just gonna go home but also my dad works
offshore so he works on an oil rig and
he this year he's scheduled to work
during the holidays luckily he gets paid
like three times is not a little good
day rate or something for working the
holiday so he's like yeah I'm gonna go
to work cuz like there's no small
children or anything and it's just like
me and him and I mean there's some other
family but usually it's kind of like it
doesn't really matter if you can get
more money he's gonna take that
opportunity but your brother my brother
is all the way on the East Coast and
he's probably gonna go to other family
that we have in Ohio so it's just like
so much distant family like my family
just so spread out that there's really
nowhere for me to go I mean I could if I
really wanted to like fly to Dallas and
see a couple ants or something but it's
just all disjointed you know so I would
rather just stay in LA and figure
something out but is it the same for all
Christmas I guess you're gonna be with
TIFF yeah this year yeah I don't like
you better yeah normally normally I try
like a lot of times like growing up
because my dad's worked offshore for so
long we've had to do the holidays not on
the holidays because a lot of times he
is gone during holidays so were you so
just having Thanksgiving or Christmas
like whatever day he's home so that's
it's not that different for me to like
be able to just get through Christmas
day like when it's not there because
I've been home alone while he's at work
like on Christmas Day but then when he
comes back we would have Christmas or
whatever but if there was any traditions
we had we would watch the Cowboys game
together and we always cuz I guess the
Cowboys for some reason we always play
on Thanksgiving but I think and they
always play like a pretty crappy team
yeah Thanksgiving so that they could win
like I don't know the Dolphins or
whoever sucks yeah nothing's really suck
yeah we always watched that and then he
makes me the like so my dad's a chef and
he actually really enjoys cooking like
really out like crazy but I always
request like the little kids version so
like I want this you wanna PB&J press
cut off like
cheap shakes us like the stovetop
stuffing from a box he's like oh god she
was the trashiest food the same thing
the cranberry sauce yeah like you know
mashed potatoes were like whatever this
stuff but like the cheap shitty like me
apart version of it and I don't know why
I think just reminds me of my childhood
because we were really poor that was our
Thanksgiving but he wants to make all
these like really nice like homemade
things and I'm like no I want the cheap
stuff six years old
I think the stall just a huge part of
the holidays and that's why I like when
traditions get broken or like something
changes it like people get divorced
speaking of sad things go first who's
the embarrassing one in your family you
want to hear about that that's not I
think there's always a job okay I have
it you're gonna be that for somebody I
think don't be that drunken aunt that
shows up with a new boyfriend every year
yeah but like I just traveled the world
I'd come back with a dopest souvenirs
and this dude's like 20 years younger
than me that's not embarrassing that's
cool that's true I'm in first show like
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay not okay you know not a
embarrassing person Helen oh no I just
have a cousin she's like kind of crazy
and when wind Joe I keep bringing him up
sorry last time I brought him to our
family like holiday thing like he met
her for the first time and I thought it
was really funny because she showed up
kind of late and drunk and she had like
her teeth are just stained with like
wine she's just like all up in
everyone's face you know like and like
she's the only one in the family like
that so it really stands out like a sore
thumb because everyone's all like kind
of prim and proper and you know my
aunt's kind of like a 1950's like diner
wife and stuff and so this lady to come
in also their daughter it's her sister's
daughter so the the one the drunk one
her mom passed away a while back but
then so yeah that's really embarrassing
so we have that lady everyone loves her
though but she's definitely not she
doesn't have it together yeah Wow I know
my whole mom's side of the family is
that person yeah cuz we're so we're like
Chinese and Vietnamese on that side so
everyone comes with a complimentary
bottle of Hennessy Oh
every every like every every wedding
we've ever been to like if one of us
gets married someone throws up oh my
home from the wedding and like the
uncles and aunts who just pass out on
the couch because all the kids are grown
now that yeah [ __ ] they want you know so
like one aunt threw up on the table the
other uncle's like halfway asleep on the
couch my mom is like just like passed
out in the bunk bed so it's almost like
Asian family in the whole entire world
that's that's how I feel about my family
- the Filipino side for sure like all
the in-laws get like super quiet all the
Filipinos are loudest back they call me
the quiet one yeah I'm like yeah
explains a lot for you too right
explains a lot have to be allowed to be
heard or like seen and like notice and
it's a houseful like my house is a house
full of females there's like yes seven
aunts and all them had girls like they
were at my birthday party and then this
is how quiet and like how they don't
know about me I took a shot with you
guys or something and then my cousin
came over she's like I been telling us
for years that you're allergic to
alcohol which is really weird yeah yeah
and they're all do they all like fight
for like the center of attention because
they are all hams in my family they're
all just trying to outdo each other and
I think that being louder is like better
but on some of the aunts yeah yeah like
definitely my mom aunt Stephanie yeah
those two on my white side it's equally
as loud and everybody is more this is
where I get like the roasts aside from
like everyone's just like sarcastic
gross sarcastic roast sarcastic gross
and it's like fun because everyone's
laughing everyone's trying to one-up the
roast and so it becomes it's like really
fun but then I come out of that and then
into a friend circle I'm like
you [ __ ] poor like whoa it's
excessive oh no I'm just trying to tell
you much of you yeah no my family is so
I do have one uncle that it's on my
mom's side and anytime he comes around
we already know we got a high dollar
[ __ ] because he steals from us do you
have the cut oh yeah it's [ __ ] up cuz
he stole like wallets and cell phone
[ __ ] from my gram like when we were at
my grandpa's funeral oh my god hell does
that yet so he's like a shitty person
invited yeah he okay so many years like
he would not come around the family but
then I guess um oh because my mom's side
there's ten kids and so he's one of them
and so I guess like other siblings they
kind of felt like oh we should connect
with their brother kind of thing so he'd
come around and then like for example my
grandpa's funeral like obviously he's
gonna be there but yeah we hate that guy
yes really that's crazy yeah and I'm I
said that at first I was like oh I have
an aunt like that but hers is more like
if there's like a like a piece of
jewelry she'll be like what's this oh my
god your face come home and like shoes
are gone like she just like feels like
my likes cute things she'll steal my
sunglasses yeah yeah no I mean no I mean
that sounds cute but it'd still be
annoying but this dude it's like no [ __ ]
off like your family cell phone pockets
you guys yeah he broke into the cars
like you know what yeah it's like that
no I mean he's shady as hell and then he
pretended to not know anything so he was
like helping us look for who stole the
and then because like I think this is
why I have such a high tolerance for
like people in my life because there
have been a lot of people in my life
that I just put up with their [ __ ] for
so long and I guess the point where I'm
like I've reached my breaking point
[ __ ] off forever you're not a part of my
life anymore and so yeah like finding
that out because we all wanted to give
him the benefit of the doubt and he he
was like helping us and stuff
and then eventually like he ended up
leaving all of our credit cards and
stuff in our in the church where we went
from my grandpa's funeral it was ugly
but eventually we're like we're never
ever ever inviting you to anything ever
again there's a wife rude or anything so
he was married before and his two kids
like I freaking love them we were one of
my favorite cousins and we got like he
doesn't I don't know man he's the kind
of guy that has kids and leaves them oh
yeah oh [ __ ] is that [ __ ] like if he
walks into the house but yeah I'll go
double and you're here to steal again
the family needs people like uncle
someone like that to like he's always
been like they're super he's like um
he owns a or he works at him or he's a
mechanic or whatever he he's a type that
would [ __ ] you over just to make more
money off of you
oh my god he's a mechanic and he did
that to our family to actually family
that's all but um so he's like he's that
and then his son grew up to be like that
too like his son used to only come
around during the first of the month to
see grandma so he can get money from her
Oh security check oh [ __ ] to the point
where like yell [ __ ] off dude like
nobody likes you and they were just
never invited ever again yeah I don't
know see people like that like family
like I'm the so I know a lot of people
will disagree but I'm the type of person
that no matter if we're connected
through blood if you're toxic you're out
of my [ __ ] life and you have no room
in my nice little happy bubble like I
don't give a [ __ ] that you're a family
member like you're out of here like I'm
not putting up with your [ __ ] oh yeah I
think that's what's hard for me is that
growing up like I was raised really like
family first and family like family's
everything and even if you have a
problem with somebody like you work it
out because like you are always gonna
need each other and have each other and
you're gonna want that support there and
blah blah blah and say that's the part
of me that I I do put up with a lot but
yes like initially that's what's driving
me to like try to connect with this
person try to understand the good in
them but it gets to the point where
I reach my threshold and I'm like that's
it yeah you're done so there's some like
kind of family drama going on right now
and um I don't know like I can't like be
like you're cut out because it's it's
kind of like I was you I was instilled
with these certain values and like you
can work it out no matter what but then
there's this other stuff going on so
yeah it's been it's been interesting
like growing up and being an adult is
weird cuz then you gotta like set your
own boundaries and rules and stuff and
you're like okay I kind of have to undo
some of the stuff that was ingrained in
me that I never questioned before it's
really hard for Asian families too
because it's like it's always like mom
and dad is always first and they're
always right head of the house you're
loyal to your family and that's it you
know and when you listen or like no
matter what that's your parents or no
matter what that's your family so but
it's hard growing up like you said you
know in a culture where it's different
like hey you cut off the toxic people's
you don't really know exactly like my
dad and I are going through that right
now we have a family member on his side
that's like yo you need to cut him off
at my dad's just like so like fiercely
loyal yeah hard for him to and I'm like
yo dude like look what he's done to our
family but he can't do it yeah I think
it's kind of like your dad cuz I think
most of my family is the same like cut
him out if they're no good most of my
family is all like on my dad's side
especially those is the main side that
I'm used to I don't know I'm not super
close with my mom's side but everyone my
dad's side is like super kind of prim
and proper besides the one drunk you
know cousin auntie and then so when my
mom cuz my mom's always been the black
sheep of our family and she's passed
away now but um so I was the one as her
daughter I was always like trying to
reach out trying to keep her like trying
to bring her to Thanksgivings trying to
bring her two Christmases my dad would
be like okay I guess like they've been
divorced for 30 years or whatever but
like everyone in the family will not
talk to her like no one's gonna have
anything to do with her but I still I'm
just like but it's Thanksgiving you know
like even though yeah so it's like
really hard even being raised in a
family where it's like cut him out yeah
I'm the only one that's like no but I
have to you know like it's weird how
like I still got that even though no one
else in the family everyone else in the
family just completely shut her out
immediately yeah
I'm like that like I cut people off
pretty not easily but it's like when I
see that it's detrimental to our family
I'm like no I don't really want you
around yeah it's hard because sometimes
that is my mother my birth mother and
we've gone through [ __ ] where I'm just
like dude what the [ __ ] you know and my
dad even though they've been divorced
for like Jesus Christ 30 40 something
years he tells me like you know that's
your mom you have to be nice so I'm just
very like my dad would be like you know
what what actually wound up happening
was really nice is that after she was
cremated I they sent the remains to my
dad's house and my dad held him there
for a long time even though he didn't
want to and then he actually took her on
a three-hour trip to the beach and then
he paddled out with his brother and did
the right thing I never grew up with my
parents so it's easier for me to kind of
cut them off like how we're gonna cut
through this ad right now oh my gosh I'm
so excited to share with you guys
our next sponsor so honey sup have you
guys heard of honey honey honey honey
honey is the first so honey is a free
browser and stick that
expressor extension thank you I can't
enunciate it so so this extension
automatically finds the best promo codes
for you whenever you're shopping online
so with the holidays coming up right now
this is a lifesaver I actually recently
used honey so I have the extension
extension and I actually used it to book
my Bora Bora
yeah it gave me some nice savings cuz it
actually filters through all these
different types of promo codes and it
even has it works with like the best
deals on over 20,000 sites such as
Amazon eBay
j.crew Sephora Expedia which is or I
booked my stuff and so it's pretty cool
so I honestly use this every single time
that I go shopping online because I have
saved some serious cash and I love it so
if you're buying gifts this holiday
season then you need honey if you're not
you probably know someone who is so do
them a solid and tell them about honey
honey can help make sure that you're
getting the best price for whatever
you're buying it's free to use and
installs in just two clicks so get honey
for free at join honeycomb slash b tch
that's join
honey calm slash b tch and start saving
some monies you know what else let me
tell you about an app called hinge here
you read the hinge ad because you have
experience so hinge is a dating F and so
I like dabbled on dated dating apps and
I never really like went on a date
because Mike this feels weird yeah it
doesn't feel personal like so I like
hinge because it feels more like the
demographic is a lot more adult and less
hookup II right yeah yeah so it's like
if I go in other apps like it's like a
waste of time yeah but then on hinge is
like there's these questions that they
fill out like a really quick question
like Oh what is it you like her what
should you not what do you not like that
you know why you should not swipe on me
and it shows their age their height what
they do for a living and you can like
link your Instagram and it just it just
felt less hookup II yeah you know and
less like CD it just felt more adult and
I love how their their motto is actually
designed to be deleted and you had it
delete
yeah Gino allegedly okay look listen you
guys don't know anything about my dating
life because I don't talk about it and
we do I always changed the dates nobody
knows what everything happened so about
16 years ago right you know so um I
actually met someone on DeAngelis so I
like I honestly kind of get on there and
if I think someone's attractive I'll
talk to them a little bit and then I
just kind of disappear because I'm not
about it but then this one we actually
ended up talking like on the app for
like six hours oh wow yeah and I was
just like all right it was meant to be
yeah and then we set up a date for the
next day oh wow long story short we did
delete the app together
ceremony is a moment we did it I know
you like it you know you like it don't
try too hard but it was cool like it was
it was just like it really as I saw it
like when I deleted it and I signed on I
said or like BB um I saw the app things
designed to be deleted I was like okay
that yeah that's pretty good that's yeah
I think that's great yeah like it's not
meant for hooking up um so when you went
on the date mm-hmm what was the quality
of the date like was it like exactly how
you guys had talked cuz I had been on
the dating up before and the guy that I
met was not the guy I was talking to he
talked nothing like how he managed okay
yeah so there was two they're not
unhinged on a different app I've been
I've been on like maybe like two dates
you know the one that we ended up
talking to like six hours we actually
went on our first date and stayed and
talked like another five hours until
like they actually had to kick us out so
that was awesome like it worked out
great and then so cute after that and
then but there was another guy too but
it's like oh my god it was it was pretty
awful I don't want sigh okay you know
this was 16 years ago who knows it's
probably the same today though so check
it out
in Jeff today all right bring it back to
a positive note from our last topic I
wanted to know if you guys have any like
new traditions that you started because
you know TIFF you're married now yes
Steve and I have started doing our own
new traditions and I think it's kind of
fun because it's like you lose this bit
of your childhood you're like you know
we're not doing that
tradition anymore but then you find this
like new thing to replace it with yeah
that's a good question because coming
into this conversation I started
thinking about it and I'm like you know
what I never realized that I did grow up
with certain traditions especially like
Mexican traditions during Christmas and
during tamales yes you get your faces
and skulls no don't do that no I didn't
even know about the like I mean I knew
about the other los muertos but my
family never did the whole tradition of
like doing the brenda's the ofrendas
none of that so when I saw Coco I was I
was like why didn't you guys share this
part of my culture with me but no like
for Christmas actually for the entire
month of December so like my stepdads
family they'd be the ones that would
really incorporate these traditions in
my childhood so they would make them III
would actually sit there with my grandma
well my stepdads mom that I call grandma
and we'd be making the thumb I'll is
like putting it on like the corn thing
amazed oh yeah thank you the corn husk
and again like they would be teaching me
like how to make them my ease and all
that stuff and then she would also make
pozole and but she would make so much
food that it would literally last us the
entire month of December so for every
meal we had pozzolan tamales like was
old like so it started these are the
freezers yeah yeah so she was like
making it again throughout the month
like you were eating the same posole
from december well they could be frozen
yeah oh my god what am i ances Mexican
and on the New Year's party it was like
a Christmas Eve party it was a potluck
and so she would bring [ __ ] tons of
tamales and we would take them home and
they would last last for the next that's
definitely a part of my childhood that I
I didn't realize I really missed like
now in my adulthood like I don't eat the
monies or passaglia
I don't do it I'm like dude I get it you
need a girl you need
girl in your face yeah you have a girl I
know I can't got nobody but like yeah
like I think about these things about my
childhood and then it makes me realize
like oh my gosh I'm really failing Isaac
because I don't have any traditions that
we have in our households because like I
said every year Christmas sneaks up on
me and I'm just like what the hell it's
already like Christmas is tomorrow
there's no decoration no so we can't
even do the tree because there's stupid
cats see it as one cats always tear down
our tree I don't even set up a tree in
our house anymore but yeah usually for
Christmas we will spend with Chan clan
and in Dallas and so Casey's mom she
does set up like the entire decorations
for the house so whenever we do spend
Christmas over there that's when we do
get to enjoy decorations but in our own
home yeah I don't put up decorations
unless I have to like film a Christmas
themed video than my god like how did I
let this happen where it's like I won't
do it on my own but if like I have to
then that's when I'll end up doing it
but even then the freakin cats take down
all the decorations no you know what you
could tie a tube sock around their
stomach they think they're frozen
[Laughter]
I was streaming yesterday and my camera
was almost like I went to the bathroom
and then I come back my like later they
clipped at that part I come back my cat
is
on the table so what happened was my
catsuit so Steve and I have couple
traditions well one was started before
Steve so one we have the cookie party
that's with my high school friends okay
and it started because like I used to
make cookies all the time with my family
and then we stopped making them cuz like
my mom was like oh they're not kids
anymore but I missed that so much so my
friends and I would take one it was just
two I only had two friends in high
school take a random day in December and
we would ditch school and we would go to
my house and we would just make sugar
cookies the Pillsbury Dough and it has
to be like wish with the sugar icing the
homemade I see you just like like I
remember doing that now oh my gosh yeah
and like one day it will be on on
frosting yeah I like mixing in the
colors and so that's how it started when
we were like 15 and we would do like a
little gift exchange and stuff and then
as we became adults we added alcohol to
the negs the party started being at
night it's
like my parents joined in and they would
like make drinks and yeah and then like
more people got added and we would like
just keep doing our gift exchange and
stuff and then Steve and I have one
where we make mulled wine well I make
the mulled wine that's my [ __ ]
God you need to try it it's so good in
moles like no it's mold mold I think
it's a German thing what is it it's
basically it's red wine apple cider mom
it's heated and then there's like
cinnamon sticks and brand okay okay I'm
done with that so good it tastes like
Christmas should make it for your
holiday party yes I will guess on the
20th you're invited whoa everyone's
invited you're invited good so yeah so
then we make them old wine and it's like
sneaks up on you it's like a jello shot
where you're like oh so delicious and
then you're [ __ ] we decorate the tree
and we have the Grinch playing in the
background well we like you just like a
little I quite I just cringe we just
like the grid
okay Harry no no the cartoon oh the
cartoons like 45 minutes long so you're
like recycling good so I got um thrusted
into the white family right yeah so um
my parents have been my stepmom I have a
Mary and then I I started spending more
Christmases with them around like five
six years ago and I remember the first
year my stepmom Jennifer hi hello
Jennifer she's like you ready for a
white family cuz we're like super white
white Christmas like yeah super white
Christmas so what we do is we open our
presents at home and then we drive out
to like two or three hours away from
where mom and dad lived this is in
Missouri so it was like it's already
cold as [ __ ] and then we meet up like a
it's like a booty call this place is
like a community center yeah oh my god
you think that is away okay it was like
it's the White House cookies certified
y-yeah in this town has like
population of six and a half or so like
it's insane and then so we meet up there
and then we go over to her dad's side of
the family and it's like a cute like one
of those big-ass mobile homes it's real
early there are be bigger Oh like I'm
right yeah like okay safely comfy
there's like four bedrooms oh yeah the
ones were like that kind of like made
their own foundations I hated house I
grew up in one of those yeah she's dope
I kind of want one
and then like I sat in a lazy boy chair
for the first time sigh turd stuffing
like pudding yeah and then like you know
grandpa's falling asleep on the couch
and like my ohio family that i barely
see but yeah it's so like Ohio Missouri
yeah yeah and my grandpa was like you
want to go you want to see the gun that
I use in the Korean War I'm like yeah
we're gonna do that we do like a white
elephant gift exchange and I think it's
very white so we got we got pocket knife
oh my god but it's like this okay so
here's the thing that I noticed when my
family so my dad's side of the family I
don't really speak to them anymore we
kind of left off on bed whatever and
they were like so prim and proper and
doctors and engineers and like super
religious but like for the most part
like half of them were kind of shitty
people and I hated them and I left that
side of family I was 14 um and we grew
up pretty like well-off you know like we
had like multiple cars big-ass house
whatever and I hated them and then like
coming to my step-mom side of the family
I was like dude like this is dope like I
love them and they love me like the
first time they met me they're like so
sweet and like like like they're they're
not you know the wealthiest but it was
they were think they're wealthy and
loving Wow yeah for sure like if they
like even if like grandpa like he
doesn't like extravagant gifts there's
no extravagant gifts he gives his candy
bars and I love that candy bar moya
anything I've ever gotten for my whole
life you know that was like this is what
like even my dad you know just
the side you know and we were talking in
Vietnamese and he goes yeah like you
know they think their life is different
in ours but they're so filled with love
and I love them and my guess my dad's
yeah that's such a G but he was like
breaking it down yeah it was really
sweet like these are like good people
you know they shout out to aunt Cathy
she's the one that I want to get to bar
fights with I love you just like that
well actually both sides are pretty much
like that they're really filled with
love and not a lot of like like money
involved but like we'll do stockings and
everything's like CVS like little like
lip glosses and stuff like that but it's
like just the feeling of opening
presents and then you thought of someone
and it's just really cute however on
Christmas Eve we play board games and if
you want to know how that side plays
board games watch any JK party episode
that I am on and then multiply hit by 20
wow that is what I'm coming over and
again and and add wine to the mix so
yeah that made me think the family cuz
I'm not super super close to like I have
so many a Mexican man I have a lot of
family yeah but but the family that
lives in Mexico so like my half-sisters
like my dad's out there my grandma
everything everyone's out there and the
few times that I have had the
opportunity to spend Christmas with them
it's an entire month of like party after
party after partner called Posadas so in
the parties are called possible the the
parties are called salsa
yeah so it's like not a party no it's
literally like that so people throw
these Posadas where they just have a
[ __ ] ton of food and everyone goes and
like just literally just has a blast and
eats a ton of food and then the next
morning they're called or like the next
day they're called like the Rick Allen
thatha's where it's like reheated food
so then people come over again and then
there's another party because they're
eating the reason every party yeah oh
dude yeah you're gonna get fat in
December otherwise you're not a part of
the family hobby pretty much yeah and so
like I remember that like those
Christmases growing up where I'm like oh
my god the Posadas are so good and then
and cuz I mean I was a kid and they're
really liberal with like
if there's alcohol around and so
sometimes I'd be like seeking beers
another way
dude I was 13 oh my god oh my it was a
Christmas that I spent out there and I
my sister and I got so wasted it was the
key lat
and no you'd be a corona or sub-nought
girl we drink half of a bottle of like
quinceanera recuerdo tequila and so it
was lit like I got da yeah I'm surprised
I didn't die because the next morning I
had a flight and then that it was it was
a mess it was so crazy and um and so my
uncle because I kept throwing up I had a
hangover oh my gosh
as he was driving me to the airport and
I literally had vomit on my jacket kids
I don't know how you drink that to you
guys like I remember we had like some
cool aunts and uncles I'd be like your
superior you know and yeah I was like 14
oh cool and I tried it drink it a bit
it's so nasty ya know how drunk cuz like
yeah I like to have fun so so if my
sister was like here girl take a shot oh
because she had some or her guy friends
come over and this is a little 13 year
old me like hormones are starting to
lately get crazy and I'm like ooh boys
and their or your little half shirt yeah
and then so like I'm like oh yeah we're
doing this we're taking shots alright
and I'll be like
began so for many years after that just
maybe until recently now I can actually
drink the key lab with every time I
didn't thought about the Keela I wanted
to bomb anytime you think about any
alcohol because you like you'll be like
is it it does it taste like alcohol
yes it's we don't imagine you just like
pounding because of that reason that's
why I am so scared of alcohol tasting
things yeah I'm hella traumatized but
that's good I know but which actually
reminds me it's so cute so you know how
boses fan-created these quizzes oh yeah
just super cute but then like so I the
first time I did that quiz I ended up
answering things that I would have
quizzes wit wit hey [ __ ] girl exactly
yeah sorry I forgot to give context but
so then I ended up doing all my answers
and I got bows and I was like oh
interesting I wonder what she thinks of
me and then one of the questions were
like well how would you rather spend
your Saturday night and then the one
that didn't sound like would be anyone
else that said like spend it out at the
bar that's a pun with that I was just
like but I ended up being me at the end
so I'm like she had a little mixed up it
was like naked with your cats in bed and
I was like like any of us would be me
but I don't like to be naked yeah it's
totally Deena nobody for sure it's hard
because one of the answers was being
naked in bed with my cat or playing
games like oh man yeah I put playing
playing games and ordering food or
something but that was both no it was
super cute though I'm like that's the
one that says Geno's like oh yeah you're
independent Bob all you could be lazy
sometimes yeah you're you're one well
guys thank you so much for tuning in
today and let us know in the comments
what you're doing for your family
traditions I would love to hear some
suggestions and ideas for new traditions
and traditions you guys have yeah
Yeah right am I gonna respond strives to
be the drunken aunts I'm telling you
that right now subscribe like I didn't
strive too hard nailed it but yeah I
subscribe also check us out on the
instagrams and we'll see you next time
also special shout out to honey hinge
native and hello fresh yeah check out
the deals in the description and save
some money thanks for feeding us saving
us money and getting laid yes and
helping us smell good
oh that smell good